[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the hot seat featuring tesh over here
what's up guys if you haven't been on
hot seat before game of thrones kingly
man first time baby what we'd like to
just get a little bit close we like to
put the heat on our guests over here get
to know them a little better but we're
going to start off a little bit cold a
little cool to warm you up into the
experiment get real sterile with bart's
questions because this question is the
most sterile you'll ever hear in your
life so go and hit it off bart yo hit me
with it bro what
pattern of carpet pisses you off uh
pisses you off
it has to piss you off it's amazing it's
like a real thing for him okay so look i
can't
answer can you give him an example i
can't answer pattern okay but i hate
shag carpets does that count like the
thick ones the thick ones that the
strands are really long to me they're
just like just dirt magnets bacteria but
if you do ecstasy and you lay on it it
feels so good
you come off all dusty though
hello right dude
you know i can't speak from experience
it's just like but what did your friends
tell you i
probably would be amazing you're not
wrong
if i was you know high on ecstasy i
think a shag carpet i would be into it
but most things are pretty cool on
ecstasy right was it get him to the
great
wall in my silver state i think i avoid
the shack carpet it feels 70s speaking
of shag do you like it shaggy or uh
you know bald on him or on on his uh i
don't know why i'm staring at ryan so
intelligently sorry help him out ryan
he's gonna hear him he's gonna step in
on your ladies come on for me whatever
they're comfortable with man
i'm very much it's yo that's not my body
i don't give a [ __ ] what about on you
for the people man you know i'll clean
it up baby hey yo
i don't like getting pulled stuck in my
teeth though but it's a good floss but
you get kind of stuck in your teeth
that's not fun so sometimes it happens
as an asian i'm a very hairy asian so i
got a lot to work on yeah like
stereotypically i heard indian people
got a lot to work on is that true yeah
any people for the most part have more
body hair i think i don't know i
personally don't that's pretty cool so
that works double fist pounds very
little same minute dude that's all there
is really so you have it just in the
places that are important like my legs
are you know what are you like no that's
not bad that's horrible yeah yeah yeah
andre got your beat
normal is that good yeah that's not my
hot seat guys i think average i would
say let's focus your guys but like dude
i don't give a [ __ ] about that [ __ ] you
got it it's dna it's genetics
collect your parents you're an actor
right yeah weirdest [ __ ] position
you've been put in as an actor
the weirdest position yeah like a doggy
style yeah yes
we're pretty close
so the first time i had to do a scene
where i i had to get intimate
uh with my scene partner guy girl uh
girl
uh it was on stitchers
if people don't realize like you've got
a whole camera crew like right here it's
not like there's a whole audience it's
weird people are like is it fun hooking
up with people i'm like
no kind of no not really yeah there's no
there's no there's no excitement or
sensuality yeah like there's chemistry
in the sense of that you're acting
together but there's a dude literally
the prop guy is sitting right next to me
as i'm pretending to have sex with my
scene partner and he's got like a light
like this close to my face and i'm like
looking over and the director is yelling
like harder
harder and i'm like looking at my scene
partner i'm like i'm sorry like this is
okay
yeah yeah
and so let me see that buddha shank
that was probably the most awkward
because i was also nervous i'm always
curious about this were you hard like
yes and no because then a part of me
would be like
well i don't it's like if it's damned if
you are because i don't want her to feel
exactly i don't want her to feel
self-conscious but i also i also don't
know if it's it's appropriate no of
course of course not and how does that
work yeah i think you just have to be
honest it's one of those things where
like as an actor you're supposed to you
were pretending for a living right and
people take their job seriously but
you're a method actor so you go hard
yeah so i need someone to flop
[Laughter]
are you guys hiring but it's just like
one of those things i think it's
important to have an honest conversation
with your scene partner
whatever happens happens i think we know
it comes with the territory what's the
rehearsal for that like when it's just
youtube they put like nude underwear on
you which for me means just like white
underwear
[Laughter]
it doesn't mean anything for me i'm like
guess what you can't see my crotch
anymore because they're not the same
color of my skin
is there rehearsal like do you and your
scene partner work on the scene and do
the physical part too over and over and
over and over and over yeah like what do
you say i did it like i don't know i
guess it depends on on the actors in the
scene yeah like it just depends like
obviously if it's something big and it
needs to be choreographed like it's just
it all depends on what the circumstances
so specifically in this circumstance
that you are no i didn't reverse it was
this like a sex scene like intercourse
concept uh yeah that's basically like
we're under a blanket because it was on
free but if you don't have a scene part
or did you rehearse with a pillow or
what
like he's never had
you know usually
i'm sorry all i'm saying is you know
there's stunt fighting and then there's
real fighting right right so there's
stun [ __ ] right the fightings usually
use pillows because i heard in porn like
the [ __ ] that they do isn't really as
good as like what really feels good
you know there's like we're not really
having sex
i wish you were but like soft core sex
was it was it comedic or just purely
romantic the sex scene it's it starts
off comedic and then goes romantic and
then ends up at the end being competing
because um
in the scenario
we're getting phone calls from our our
uh lab partners like some [ __ ] has gone
down and we're not getting phone call
because we're into each other and then
obviously they showed me like where the
[ __ ] are you like what were you doing
and it was like well uh you know
oh no no no
no like one of those what is the honest
conversation you have with your scene
partner i usually defer to the partner
especially if it's female and i just say
look i'm i'm here for you whatever
you're comfortable with i'm comfortable
with anything that makes you
uncomfortable
just stop you tell me is there a safe
word
no don't just stop it's not like no dude
there's this one
around you is that called for can i grab
her titties if the scene requires it but
that's a conversation you need to have
with your seat part and then the same
way goes the other way you know am i
allowed to grab you can i invite you
guys
is it appropriate to the scene you're
not going to do something that's not
appropriate it's not even in the script
you guys ever like like because you're
laying on top of her right yeah with the
blanket do you go can we do it for reals
under here
did you ever ask her dude you'd be a
good actor here no cause you're not like
in uh in creed and creed uh uh sylvester
stallone wanted to knock michael b
jordan not so he knows what it feels
like right so he got a real knockout i'm
like do you ever go like we gotta do we
gotta we got this stallone style
that's the industry
there's a great espn have you heard of
sylvester stallone
he has this technique it's called
sylvester i don't know if he'll be
working very much after that if i
employ stallone style but i thought
that's what brad pitt and angelina jolie
did on mr mrs smith and that's why they
became together we're off camera yeah
off camera well it's because they they
rehearsed too much they were stallone
styling for sure they rehearsed so much
that they fell in love yeah what if the
the girl said that to you
oh stallone style i would honestly i
could get nervous
i would be like i'd be like says it that
way she goes i want it stallone style my
team partner was like stallone style as
we've we've called it
as we've defined you're like you watch
jk news
this is just a hollywood turn yeah like
this is just
this is it would throw me off man it
would definitely throw me off
yeah i would i would i would like to
think i'd be cool and calm and
collective
let's get rocky tesh
until tester stallone
did you ever get a boner in any scene
where you had to apologize like a fight
scene
[Laughter]
no it's weird it's hard because your
mind is in a different place
your mind is deaf in a different place
because you're working you're working
you're working the mentality is
different it's hard to explain to
somebody
what the energy in the atmosphere is
because you have to give a believable
performance but at the same time it's
not you're not in an intimate setting
yeah like they try to make it intimate
yeah they're like okay all non-personnel
has to get offset like so if you're not
in the scene you're not gonna be hanging
out but there's still 80 people
hanging out like you know and there's a
[ __ ] furry thing like like
non-personnel scene like now you
probably you're gonna be like nowadays
if you're doing it there's gonna be
maybe like you know 10 15 people and
they're all gonna be wearing masks and
you're like where the [ __ ] am i you're
gonna look like you're in a lab
experiment with the lights right you got
the boom mic dude he's like standing
over you you're like well okay
like your ass is hitting the mic like
you never know what's going on right how
tight is your frame yeah it's a very
technical thing how tight is her frame
because you don't know stop covering
your face don't put your hand on their
face like all right so then you're like
where do i put my hands where do i
should i put them here my titties is
it's okay is this okay yeah like you
know then you're like you're like i
guess i'll just put my hands here
while you're making love that's the
[ __ ] thing
is this sexy like you know you start
doing it then yourself and then you're
self-conscious i think you're like do it
you're not thinking about do i have a
boner because your hands are pure
you're like you know what i mean because
he's gonna get in the way of the shot
yeah exactly today's video is brought to
you by amazon music
since you're listening to this show i
think it's safe to assume that you like
podcasts and comedy talk shows right yes
well you'll find a lot of top
binge-worthy podcasts and talk shows
like this on amazon music amazon music
has more than 10 million free podcast
episodes to listen to like the
breathtaking true crime podcast dr death
miracle man it's available two weeks
early on amazon music but amazon music
isn't just for listening to podcasts
they have thousands of music stations
and top playlists to stream for free and
no matter what you're listening to you
can go hands-free with alexa and if
you're like me and you want music on
demand and ad-free you have to try
amazon music unlimited that gives you
unlimited access to over 75 million
songs as well as podcasts music videos
and more
with amazon music unlimited you can
listen to any song
anywhere
offline with unlimited skips one of my
favorite things to do is play amazon
music
i go alexa play and we'll play games
when megio and tiger are cooking and
we'll play different games where we go
okay we're gonna name songs that have
food ingredients like peaches and cream
or we'll go oh well
we'll name songs that have numbers in
them and we just make this a fun game
and since it's hands-free and it's on
alexa we just play that until someone
loses and we just have a fun family time
that's nice music so if you want to
listen to a bunch of music super
convenient hands-free offline online
make sure you give it a try because
right now you can try for three months
unlimited for free go to amazon.com otr
pod to try it for three months
unlimited for free and see if you like
all the music and podcasts and all the
different shows that they have on there
go to amazon.com otr pod that's crazy
how boners work because they come when
you don't want them to and then they
they don't appear when you need them but
also isn't it hard to have a boner when
your focus is on complete something you
know it's it's look it's a double-edged
sword pardon me if i do pardon me if i
don't yeah that's pretty right
that's for sure don't take it as an
insult don't take it as a compliment it
just mine's a one-sided blade mine's
more like a cleric's mace
that's pretty tight
so what's uh what's something that you
worked on that you're like most proud of
uh
man
one of my most was it your role of ken
and and barbie and ken i i'm very proud
of that finally became
dude
that's definitely a very cool
accomplishment
i think every opportunity i get to be on
screen for me i'm i'm i'm i'm proud
you know including these screens these
screens too to get a platform to be able
to just sort of uh speak you're one of
the guys that didn't big-time us after
they got in film you know you came back
thank you very much are people big time
john oh this is a stepping stone like
i've always said this is the high school
fast food job for people
and sometimes it's this it's the place
of second chances i'm trying to retire
here yeah yeah me too i love him some
people
this is fun for me they had a career and
then a [ __ ] complete downward spiral
and then they come back they come here
they come here to work i guess i'm in a
downward spiral right now
no you were so low that became all that
great that's true i went upwards like we
typically you know
attract people who have nothing else
going for them at [ __ ]
i don't know
i'm like where do i fall on this
spectrum
you know i guess he ain't coming back
bro
i always say this like don't take it as
an insult or a compliment a lot of the a
lot of the roles that i've booked uh um
have been i don't they're like open
ethnicity they're not necessarily indian
characters they become indian after i
get the job
and so for me it's
it feels good because it means one i
feel validated that i'm able to compete
with the larger community and it's not
like oh we're just looking for a south
asian person so it's like a list of 10
of us it's like no
we're having open auditions and it's
like we like this guy the most what got
you into acting cause you majored in it
in college yeah i loved so growing up i
loved martial arts like my two biggest
things that i loved watching was uh like
michael jackson
and
and martial arts movies both had kicking
yeah
yeah exactly and so sweet movie yeah
like so old bruce lee movies jackie chan
van damme steven scott like all those
crazy 90 action flicks i love those two
um she's like a regular asian dude like
you know schwarzenegger all that [ __ ]
and then you know
just loving song and dance i got big
into taekwondo growing up and so like i
wanted to be a power ranger i wanted to
be like an action star
and that sort of slowly morphed into me
you know getting into singing and then
dancing was always like a big hobby of
mine and so then i was doing musicals
and then i was like i don't want to be a
doctor both my parents are doctors they
they were they pushing that on you they
never really pushed it i
always was interested in it like i found
it interesting um
but i once i
was exposed to performance that's what i
fell in love with and then i was like
this is what i want to do for the rest
of it like what was your was it like a
school play or something that you're
like i'm macbeth [ __ ] i did macbeth in
11th grade yeah i played macbeth yeah of
course yeah so that was that was
i hated my life because i was like oh
should i make memorize my lines or like
study for my sats yeah
but i knew uh when i was in second grade
we did a magic school bus musical
and we had to sing
and i remember because i always grew up
being the smallest kid smallest
skinniest kid always basically until i
was like 18.
and i was like oh i guess i can kind of
sing and it was the first time that i
was like oh i'm naturally good at this
because like i wasn't i was quick but i
wasn't strong you know and obviously i
was smart but that's not cool
you know now obviously that's all
changed
what's up what's the role that you're
like
oh man i don't know if i should take
this but i know it's gonna be better for
my career but i personally don't really
like this or have you ever even taken a
role like that i haven't encountered
that yet
um
i haven't encountered that yet most of
the stuff that i do if i'm taking the
job i feel like it's going to push my
career forward
i hope one day things go so well that
i'm like ah you know it's a luxury right
i can turn it down i have obviously
turned down auditions before where i
feel like oh i don't think this is going
to push forward or i'm not going to
learn anything i try not to take jobs
just for financial gain
oh yeah we are different baby um that
being said because we're at the 15
minute 21 second mark where we like to
take it real real close get a little bit
warm what clip of you online can we look
up right now that you would be most
cringy and embarrassed by if we all
watch aw [ __ ] uh probably a video
well this for me this is funny i was in
the zumba video game
so you like choose your instructors yeah
and so i taught bhangra in the zuma
video game and so me and my buddy
are
instructors you can choose so so type in
type in zumba world
party bhangra type in rotate wong fu i
think that's probably the cringiest one
oh yeah that's pretty cringy any a lot
of those wong fu projects get
interesting man they make me throw up
did i look at them
they make me throw up
it was in a wong fu video that's what we
met i watched myself in a wongfu video
and [ __ ] threw up on my dick dude
yeah waffle is just a little grinch
isn't it that one
there's there's a yeah that was a
bollywood song
look it was cool i i had a lot of fun
but like i'd watch this and i'm like
what the
[ __ ] you gotta watch a little bit of
this we got at least at least it's like
culturally like it's cool at least this
is a successful and i will say this it's
it's real
it's not like your bollywood [ __ ]
bunga southeast blocking it
[Music]
so it does like the motion thing it does
it does like oh there they are you're in
the you're in [ __ ] meta world indian
yeah this is the
this is meta taj mahal bro
yo this looks like an indie music video
quite the journey bro
this is tight
so we used to teach zumba structures
bunga so i used to teach at the
conference and stuff like that so i used
to teach full-time in los angeles wow
and the better you did the more
background dancers you got
so they would pop up
oh that's sick
i want to learn this yo let's try it
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up wait that's his
girlfriend
is there like a redhead australian girl
dude i don't remember i did this ten
years ago i think that's my girlfriend
that's goodness
i knew this i set this whole [ __ ]
thing up i set the whole
joke i waited ten years for she told me
one of her most cringe things is this
too
at least we're on the same page
but she's not indian so that's why oh
that's so cool
you should teach us how to do this
as it should be what a small world we
should learn how to do this dance i was
on a dance team in college that did hip
hop and bunga we were like a fusion
dance team so that's kind of where
my where i was i learned bhangra taught
bunga and then i moved out here and
worked at pf chang's and then i got
roped into zumba and i was like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
well we're gonna i'm gonna teach dance
now so i like lost 15 pounds because i
stopped eating like lettuce cups and
spare rooms yeah the lettuce cupcakes
wraps dude
feel like all actors have the craziest
like
roster of jobs while they're trying to
get on a roll well it's like a weird
thing because you grow up right i grew
up in a south asian family like
traditional in the sense of that we
value education my parents were all
doctors you did well in school and then
i'm like oh man i gotta drive uber and
like do all this [ __ ] when like all my
friends are investment bankers or in
medical school or lawyers and they're
coming out of college and making like
200 000 and i'm making 20 an hour if i'm
lucky and so it's it really makes you
question did i make the right choice
because this is all right and do you
laugh in their faces now oh i mean i
don't look i'm ken [ __ ]
i always say i'm blessed and for me it's
like i want to be able to push the
culture forward you know so while i say
the zumba thing is like a cringy thing
because personally it's like cringy i'm
very happy that i was able to put
bhangra on a on a national international
stage right now i've exposed bungra to
thousands of people personally like i
can say that and that's something i'm
really proud of yeah man just say the
real thing you just want to be like i am
having the time of my life that too hey
you are miserable you son of a [ __ ] you
should laugh about it you got to make it
that way you got to make it that way
right like i could have sat there and be
like [ __ ] should i have gone to business
school or medical school or this is fun
take my talents to hollywood
let's
go that's that's tight dude that's cool
that you still work jobs even though
both your parents are doctors like yeah
they didn't throw you any money
yeah my dad made a deal with me and my
parents were always gracious he was like
look you gotta take care of what you
need to spend on if you need money like
i'll help you yeah but i don't want you
to waste your time doing dumb [ __ ] like
spend your time and energy becoming a
better artist yeah and they've always
had that mentality so like if you're
gonna spend money
like push the needle forward right like
otherwise what's the point if i'm
working in a restaurant [ __ ] 100
hours a week i'm not getting better i'm
not getting better i'm not going to book
a job i'm not getting i'm not becoming a
better actor a better singer better
dancer better artist right so if the
goal is to make money being an artist i
have to
be a better artist how do i do that
absolutely probably not pf chang's pf
tanks although i can tell i can i can do
a bomb order for you guys you know
[Music]
you